من جديد في الدوحه نعرضوا اكسبو قطر 2023
للبستنه اكبر حدث عالمي يقام هنا منذ
بطوله كاس العالم
المعرض وافتتحه امير قطر بحضور عدد من
رؤساء الدول والحكومات بمشاركه 80 دوله
بهدف مكافحه التصحر وتعزيز المساحات
الخضراء باستخدام احدث تقنيات الاستدامه
لكن ما الذي يميز هذه النسخه من اكس بوكس
هو الاول من نوعه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وفي دوله ذات مناخ صحراوي وما
زاده اهميه هو انسجامه مع شعار صحراء
وخضراء بيئه افضل المبنى الرئيسي لاكسبو
دخل موسوعه جينيس العالميه للارقام
القياسيه لامتلاكه اكبر سطح اخضر في
العالم
[موسيقى]
الحدث يمتد على مساحه مليون وسبعمائه متر
مربع حيث اقف هنا في حديقه البدع اقدم
واشهر الحدائق في الدوحه ثلاثه ملايين
زائر من المتوقع صدورهم هنا وسيستمر
المعرض سته اشهر
اننا نتطلع من خلال هذا المعرض العالمي
الى مبادرات وشراكات جاده تعيد الامل لنا
والاجيال المقبله بعالم يحفل بحياه امنه
اكسبو الدوحه حكايه جديده عنوانها
المعاصره المبنيه على اسس الاصاله والجمع
بين التراث والابتكار امال عريضه بايجاد
افكار وحلول للمشاكل البيئيه التي تواجه
معظم دول العالم